so what we're saying that when you look
at Islamic teaching to summarize it for
you Islam came to preserve five things
all right Islam came to preserve five
things
so the first one Islam came to preserve
religion
so what does that mean when we say Islam
reservation mean that in Islam
worshiping Allah alone
worshiping the true God is very
important that's why paganism atheism
politicism is forbidden
because I will demonstrate to you later
on what is the outcome of not worshiping
the true God okay so Islam came to
preserve that secondly Islam came to
preserve the intellect
that's why in Islam alcohol and drugs is
forbidden because it affects intellect
yeah
thirdly Islam came to preserve wealth
that's why interest and gambling is
forbidden okay fourthly Islam came to
preserve marriage
that's where fornication adultery is
forbidden lastly Islam came to preserve
life
that's why committing suicide killing
people and Justice forbidden but we have
to understand when Islam forbid when
Islam came to preserve that notice by
just saying stay away from it no there's
a barriers
because Allah wants good for mankind
and if we break these five Necessities
then what happened to us let us go back
to no Worship in the true God if you do
not worship the true God we start
following our own desires the outcome of
that bro we can observe that you know
the camera they work blurry we can
observe that yeah
now man wakes up if he gets a woman
a woman wakes up Vick is a man
it doesn't stop here bro now people are
waking up he says I believe I'm a dog
but I'm trapped in a human body
yeah brother this is not normal you
understand this is not normal and the
problem that try to force that on us
you know there's a guy he raped two
women
he raped two women yeah
why it is smart why did so he was going
for a trial so he knew they're gonna
find him guilty he went and he dressed
like a woman and he said on his paper
yeah he identified himself as a woman so
what what I have to put him away
for him now he's in Paradise that's
Paradise for him that's what he wants
you see and that's what Allah
and the meaning of the verse if the
truth follow people desires the heavens
and the Earth be corrupted
that's why the Islamic legislation
against people desires because what
people desire is I want to like you want
to do crazy stuff you understand that
will harm us you understand so likewise
if we don't want to be true God alcohol
drugs what is interest interests make
the ritual
instead an interest is a type of slavery
for example I know okay I know you need
you need money yeah and when they do
they study
how people not how people can pay and so
on so I know you need seven thousand
Pounds
and I think you know what I know by two
weeks I'm gonna tell him listen I'm
gonna give you seven thousand pound you
have to give it back to me as ten
thousand in two weeks but I know you
cannot do that so by two weeks I said
this is no problem I can wait for you
what you do give me more and keep adding
and put that on a big scale
so I'm making myself richer that's why
when you look at those who are very
hostile to Islam because these five
things is good for us individually
collectively these five things Islam
came to preserve and the opposite of
this five Universal Necessities drugs a
fornication interest that destroy our
societies individually collectively
that's why I'm majority of times those
who are very hostage Islam those who are
in power
you know why because I'm making money
from these vices that's it so imagine
they're making money how gonna be mad
Rich so what they're gonna do they hang
on the only Revolution that is going
against our agenda and our desires is
Islam okay we are rich so what we're
gonna look we're going to look to what
is the most effective weapon to stop
Islam which is Media so they utilize the
media to make Islam look bad even though
Islam is good for us
understand look the uh
even if I show you how crazy it is yeah
I was given a talk to to the youth to
the young Brothers in mosque yeah and I
told them you know
singers and rappers they should not be
our role models because these guys not
all of them but majority of them they
get manipulated
and they've been used by the secrets
that's it people on the top in the stand
yeah for example brother back in the
days like you know I respect to people I
know but we should not just blind full
of fashion back in the days if I saw
someone walking with the trousers with
ripped everywhere our figure is a
crackhead oh he's begging he's a beggar
in the stand but now to to to normalize
that for us what they do big companies
they choose a rappers they say you wear
it we pay you big money and we stop
trying to follow them in the stand so we
have to understand that's why there's a
usual endless Islam because Islam
removes you from the slavery of your
desires and the slavery of society to
become the slave of the most high and
when you become the slave the most high
that's the true meaning of freedom
does it make sense what I said so far
you understand so why we say to you also
this all you have to understand brother
how now the as I say the the cake now
how men that existed
1400 years ago Prophet Muhammad who
couldn't read and write his commune is a
perfect way of life which is good for us
individual collectively on the other
hand we have these politicians or the
governments around the world studied in
the best universities around the world
yet they cannot really of the problems
because Prophet Muhammad he received the
Revelation from the most high the
Creator and Allah knows what is good for
us in details
to show you the contradiction yeah when
we start following our own desires and
when we turn away from God literally
there's off-license
selling alcohol
if a drug dealer goes there next to the
shop and starts selling drugs he will
get arrested
and you'll be sent to prison but guess
what alcohol is more harmful than drugs
so why the shopkeeper is not getting
arrested
is making money because alcohol you
understand that's what Allah that's why
when human legislate something
there's evil desires involved in the
stand but when a larger State something
is perfect in the stand so my point here
is to always say to your brother if it
makes sense to you the example I want to
give to about the two eyes if I said you
look bro
imagine I said you look I'm a
billionaire is someone smoking bro
someone else oh it's gone
because I assumed me back in the day is
a crazy weather but I forgive us man
remind you of Central London man took me
back from way back you know
what I would say to you bro
imagine I said to you look bro I'm a
military millionaire
I will give you I will give you two
million pounds as a gift
like just if you do take it if you do
take it what would you say to me at
least
two million pounds big money but if you
go Barbados I think you become a leader
two million pound is a big money bro you
buy my nice house nice car in the stand
I will give you two million pounds on a
condition give me your two eyes
you wouldn't because why your eyes is
more valuable than anything else you
know when you're blind you become like a
burden you know literally you have to
rely on people you understand that's why
in Islamic teaching if Allah tested
someone by taking his sight and his page
upon that and is a Believer there's no
reward for him except Paradise
in the stand because the blessings you
understand so you you will remember me
all the time you'll be very grateful to
me okay not but like I said
the one who gave you two eyes for free
why are we not grateful to him
understand that imagine in the house may
Allah forbid and you wake up in your own
room and there's a fire everywhere
you try your best to serve yourself you
did everything but you couldn't I came
and I saved your life you know what
thank me bro I saved your life bro you
will remember me all the time
I never gave your life
so likewise we should be grateful give
us a life for free if you want to buy a
gift for your mother would you give that
your love or your mother love
likewise logic dictates if I want to
worship my Creator be grateful to him I
should worship him the way he wants not
the way I want that's what Allah
be open uprightness the way you have
been commanded not according to your
desire the one you be commanded
so that's the true testimony the two
testimonies will become Muslim the other
witness that my Creator should worship
him alone and according to his teaching
which is Muhammad the messenger of Allah
there's many prophecies that Prophet
Muhammad mentioned for example he said
it will come a time when you see a woman
dressed but are naked at the same time
person must say it doesn't make any
sense if they are naked they cannot be
dressed but we see that right now you
understand so also Prophet Muhammad
mentioned because in December we as a
Muslim when you believe Islam you can
take it for free
yeah it's one I guess it's warning yeah
and speaks about the details how
Al-Qaeda and Isis started yeah the
origin
yeah yeah so so
Islam is based upon proves and evidences
no no it's free the one who created you
is the same one who send down Islam
if it makes sense create you are invite
to become Muslim
you can leave you know I'll say to you
baba yeah you can live this life anytime
that is a fact how many years you've
been cutting off from worshiping your
creator
you know Prophet Muhammad
they always they told us go visit the
graveyard you know why because the
people who are inside the graves they
were like you and I walking streets they
never expect they would die at the age
of 16 or 18 or 30. you understand drop
dead that's what our Prophet Muhammad
called deaf Allah Called Death destroy
of desires
because all of us I want to have a nice
car a nice woman you know nice watch
this and that by the time you know it
death come surprise you
that's what Allah Allah said Allah said
prepare yourself for tomorrow meaning
for the day of judgment and the prophet
Muhammad told us he said if you're
traveling imagine you're traveling to
Algeria Morocco yeah of course you're
gonna take
something that you need in Morocco
Algeria yes likewise we're gonna travel
from this life to the hereafter
any person with the Sounders in a smart
person a wise person is going to take
something that will which he needs in
the Hereafter and Allah already clarify
to us is your belief and the righteous
actions which is please your creator not
according to our forefathers or culture
yes we respect our culture as no does
not go against God's teaching because
God is the ultimate you understand so
how many people left the houses they
never come back how many people were
asleep they never wake up and Allah has
an attribute of anger and mighty but
also has attributes of mercy and love
that's why based upon his anger and
mighty and power he create the Hellfire
and based upon his mercy and love we
create Paradise
is so powerful Allah create Adam without
a man or a woman
then Allah created Jesus from a man not
a woman I'm sorry then Allah creates Eve
from a woman and from a man not a woman
yeah then Allah create Jesus from a
woman not a man Allah create the Hell
Fire which is pure evil and they create
Paradise which is pure good and it
create this life which is mixed even
good
to show you how powerful everything is
connected so if you really want goodness
is to follow God's teaching that's what
Allah put us in this to test us
in the stand
that's why we said you are invited to
become Muslim except Islam you know
would you have any question
you can ask any question that comes to
your mind
yeah yeah
okay what we say to you hello what would
say to you bro yeah I said look no doubt
it's good to read yeah but I would say
if you're making sense to you and they
say you know what this makes sense I
believe this is true you understand what
is topology accepted imagine
this we have to understand imagine you
die today because nothing's guarantee in
this except death yeah imagine you die
today
and Allah the creator of evening ask you
why you rejected the truth which excuse
you think you will say to him that will
save you from his punishment
which exclusive think you have
nothing that's what I'm saying you know
what two days ago a brother became
Muslim yeah same thing he learned about
Islam and he was asking how do I become
Muslim and when I told him that you know
what it's true because you know what
happened now Prophet Muhammad told us
when someone was accept Islam
say it in our clear enemy He's Not Gonna
Let You Go free bro he's going to try
his best to stop Islam he's going to
bring whatever your family what about
this what about that but all these
excuses is not valid that's why majority
of times those who doesn't accept Islam
either they have like a social reason
or psychological reason s
arrogant okay or they something they
they do some evil things which they
cannot stop
against that okay or social reason then
if they accept Islam their family and
guess them or they have status in their
society about accepting Islam people
will not respect them anymore yes but
what I would say to you you have nothing
no valid reason to accept the truth
today
which doesn't make any sense bro you
understand and I always give the example
imagine you have a big cake in front of
you nice cake big massive if you eat all
of it at once at one one time it's all
of it straight away what happened to you
you get sick yeah and what happened you
vomit to feel the sweetness of the cake
bit by bit
that's why except to Islam step by step
the first because you know the biggest
sin against Allah is atheism paganism
politicism turn away from him because if
you accept Islam today and you live
straight away except if you have a debt
because you are recognizing nurse
recognizing accept it and worshiping
your creator
then of course it's a prayer a step by
step bro step by step like you know when
I told you if I saved your life you
never said to me let me think deep about
it
you said straight away thank you and I
remember you you understand look while
we're speaking brother we are benefiting
from His blessings oxygen in out if you
go to hospital they charge you for the
oxygen
and you can end it for free
don't let it stop bro it's a big step
but but it is a step toward your creator
huh
it's a step do you create a brother your
life this Baba is a revert like I said
to the guy
have Jamaican of English yeah yeah
Abdullah bro ready
if you become Muslim I got reward bro
you know what I don't want to put
pressure on you but what I I'm what I'm
doing before that's why I always explain
to people if it makes sense to you is it
clear because by we know Prophet
Muhammad told us when someone wants to
become Muslim Satan will try to stop him
and the state is our clear enemy and
Yusuf admitted to us openly yeah that
you have no valid reason for not
accepting the truth
doesn't make any sense bro bro you know
what because Satan doesn't want to be
connected to your creator that's why
he's stopping you to share the ten yeah
it feels so good yeah no doubt brother
is a burden good 10 20 minutes yeah
brother is a burden
yeah well that is a burden I'll show you
the the guy that became Muslim yeah I'll
show you one second yeah
uh
he was like you yeah I was crying man do
you know why I told him
yeah yeah do you know why brother you
see like that's what I'm saying Islam is
that Allah is the creator of everything
the one who gave you everything
is the one that is calling to worship
alone you understand and you know what
that's what beauty of Islam I've
explained everything so it makes sense
to make sense to you
and it is the truth no doubt about it
you understand
Islam you feel good because why now you
have a purpose
step by step share that said
witness there is nothing worthy of
worship except Allah which you recognize
you acknowledge and I will bear with
Muhammad the message of Allah based upon
a Clear Proof legislation I came with
through the guy you know the brother he
became Muslim Andrew Tate but that guy
look he saw he said I saw the Satan with
my own eyes
is the only religion that makes sense
and is stopping against the evil one is
Islam
and you know yesterday his uh business
manager became Muslim
yeah
that's what I'm saying he makes sense
clear bro so this will you accept Allah
as you created alone Muhammad the
messenger of Allah now when you become
true Servants of Allah other than that
you just follow up your desires slave
our desires
accept Allah as my Creator you know
yeah that's what I'm saying Satan now is
playing with your mind brother
yeah
don't think about
righteous in front of God think about it
it's right now what shouldn't he say
s
inconvenience you if you're true to me
that's all you have to understand is it
true to me do I believe that it is my
heart content with it and then it's a
stepping stone sort of thing from there
that's what I feel like a New York City
to read into it no problem
principles are so clear the principles
yeah and the reason why we
iterated
giving us your time it shows that you're
off the truth you know you know the
reason why he came here today you know I
was watching your YouTube channel yeah
and all I said was uh this probably has
a lot of knowledge he took it he took
the phone off my hand I said let me see
he was watching it I said
[Laughter]
you said a lot of things going into your
mind and again that is look that's why I
said you do you have any valid reason if
you have valid reason I understand but
there's what is good in your mind for
not letting you accept the truth is
Satan
and if you know someone's your clear
enemy you know this person is my enemy
would you listen to him
okay so state is your enemy Allah is not
your enemy Allah what's good for you so
you choose it now okay except it makes
sense it's the truth you understand
that's why when people take Shadow not
everyone some people crying because when
they recognize this is the truth when
you become when you start praying like
you know Islamic look how many how many
depressions depression is high
stress is high why because we turn away
from God when you appreciate to Allah
you don't understand that feeling you
know the most honorable you face is on
the ground to home not actually not to
animal no or not to son or a star to the
creator of everything
that feeling you receive that's why you
know you know the the the
suicide is very low amongst the Muslim
Community yeah of course brother well
it's commit suicide because you know
some people they think will you commit
suicide is the end it's not the end
that's the beginning of punishment yeah
yes
yeah to get to the worst situation you
know that's why we'll be patient up on
everything that's what I said brother
you should become Muslim if you make
sense it's clear to you then are you
going to see how you feel
that slightly please walk away sinless
except without debts if you have a death
you have to pay it back let's show you
justice Islam
you're not saying like you're also on
money yeah
you still owe them that 50 pounds or you
took your stereo or something like that
yeah you have to try to give it back you
know I mean
that shows you yeah because that's the
right for the people not the rights of
Allah yeah because yeah there's a right
about to learn the right to the people
and that is still in this Haram which
you break in Allah's right so also
you're taking the person's item which is
that's his right
Islam
if you're not going to leave tomorrow
and it makes sense you know what is the
truth you know it makes sense to me you
know like you know you you go to the GP
you don't have to know everything about
your GP your doctor about shoe size and
everything but you trust him why because
you're working with a foundation he's an
expert you understand that's why Islam
the foundation is so clear you you
gravitate towards Islamic teaching
naturally because you go with your
nature you understand that you know
about this universe five Universe
Universal necessity that is still come
to preserve the intellect about
worshiping the true God you know about
the wealth and everything is so perfect
so that's why Islam is good for us
psychologically spiritually physically
socially economically everything
and that only comes from who if it's
perfect from the Creator
you know
announce that to the whole world is
between you and what
remember
this moment is unique it may not come
back again many people have
conversations with us
about God's permission that let's come
back they get you know influenced by
other Persuasions in life yeah but the
fact that you've given us your time
which is valuable which we can put no
price on
to be true
then we say you know yeah why
I remember the Satan shots
don't delay
man
you know but it's still your decision
yeah yeah we're just taking it from our
perspective nobody ever comes back to us
and says I wish I did do that they
always thank us yeah yeah we thank Allah
they always thank God yeah they did it
they never say you know what shouldn't
see I did it last Friday I wish I never
did it oh they come I said I'm glad I
did it yeah I'm glad I did it you know I
mean because when you're first
you drink water you replenish yourself
and you know do away with the first you
never say oh I wish I never drank that
water yeah of course it's not connected
you're not connected to uh when you
become Muslim you're close to your
creator
yeah yeah you come to your true creator
bro the one who gave you everything the
one you know it's like you recognize
that but you say you know what give me a
time
and the one who gave you everything
brother
piece of cake
yeah
it takes time
ready
to become Muslim
alhamdulillah
Allah
Allah in English I bear witness there's
nothing there's nothing worthy of
worship in truth except Allah
is the last messenger is the last
messenger and the servant of Allah
Brotherhood now you see the Brotherhood
that's right Islam bro the Brotherhood
I'm happy for you bro
come on
yeah yeah you give him the book you give
him the book which one he's got this
this Islam
Islam yeah yeah brother I'm very happy
for you man we're live brother you know
worshiping the true one
the one that deserves
smell it smell it maybe some drugs man
don't judge American you Barbados no
church
that is a nice nephew nice perfume it's
nice it's a nice perfume yeah
we have to understand bro there's many
people walking past us
Allah chose you you understand remember
the one who's not in need of nothing
chosen you to accept the truth because
you know what Allah Prophet Muhammad
told us Allah doesn't look at our skin
color or our bodies and I looked at our
hearts and also our actions you know and
Allah mentioned you know the the Allah
mentioned that those who are not sincere
Allah misguided but if you sincerely
seeking the truth Allah will guide your
truth you know because Allah Allah Allah
Allah doesn't want to punish his
servants you know but Allah and the
people like to be punished you know
people they know the truth mama look you
knew the truth you recognized it for
about to say you know what I'm going to
accept Islam you know Muslim means
submit to Allah Allah it's a big
blessing brother I'm very happy for you
man yeah we're alive trust me my trust
me yes my God's permission we say make
us happier yeah alhamdulillah you know I
mean look we didn't we ask her to
forgive us Allah is a blessing you know
it's a blessing that you accept Islam
you know because why we born some us
born in the Muslim family some us born
in a Christian family and all of that
but Islam is the teaching of Allah is
just that's why Allah will never punish
people until the truth has been
clarified to them
you understand probably just think you
know think why there's a huge war
against Islam against Christianity
against Islam is you know what in
Holland Australia Britain you know
islamophobic is crazy you know
because why like we said there's people
on the top secret society you know their
art wants to destroy him in nature and
they know if human stick to the nature
they will gravitate towards Islam
because Islam go in line with human
nature so that as you throw it and
corrupt it oh corrupt Islamic teaching
which they cannot do that but maybe
there will be some Hypocrites try to do
that in the stand so I'm very happy for
you that you accept Islam
bless him